the jurogan experience dude i remember
when
you lost your job at nickelodeon we were
in the parking lot of john jocks
and this is like what year was that um
that had been
you know what it had been 98 yeah 98
because i had a house
i just bought a town home in valencia
yeah and we were talking you're like
[ __ ] i don't know what to do yeah
like i'm thinking you know but just like
just you know
working on my art i remember that
conversation man
and then i remember like years later
you're bawling out of control in your
arts and galleries
and i had a friend and i went over his
house and he had one of your [ __ ]
paintings above his kitchen table i was
like
holy [ __ ] that's todd white's painting
yeah he's like you know that guy
i go i do jujitsu with him i'm like wow
he's really talented it's really good it
was like one of those cocktail
party paintings i remember thinking this
is nuts man
i'm at someone else's house and todd
white's painting
is above his [ __ ] kitchen table it
was wild i love that
i was telling you the other day or just
earlier today rather that um
sure the restaurant out here yeah i go
in had no
idea i just go in me and my wife around
date night we walk in and i'm like this
[ __ ] todd white's paintings are
everywhere
yeah thank you it's it's well your style
is so distinctive
you know i could see you're like either
someone's ripping you off
or it's you so like when i walked in
there i'm like i'm 99
sure this is tom white or some todd
white copier
it's uh so you know i had i had
13 years in animation i came out of high
school i got a job at warner brothers
as a care as a production assistant on
the first season of tiny toons
but but what i did is i just i looked at
every
super talented artist every draftsman
and i i would ask questions and
i was drawing every day i had no social
life and
they would give me such great advice so
i looked at it that's my college because
i didn't go to school
my mom was a painter so i grew up in a
painting household her mom was as well
and i just looked at it as i'm gonna
educate myself
through you know the hard work and the
grind and
before i knew it i was just around some
of the most talented artists in the
industry
and they were showing me techniques and
and
way to the way to put life into
character and a way to give
a drawing life which is the hardest
thing by the way i look at a lot of
paintings and
it they may be technically great but
there's no life they're dead looking
the eyes are dead it's a dead looking
painting and so i
learned through super talented
artists to teach me how to put that kind
of
personality and life into the drawing
and then translate that into the
painting
and i was always obsessed with the rat
pack and sinatra and dean martin and
sammy davis jr and i just
i would i had vhs tapes of them at the
summit and everything and i used to
watch them all the time and try it they
looked like they were having so much fun
god men were men and women were dames
and they had the drinks and the
cigarettes and they were blowing smoke
in each other's face and they weren't
worried about
masks it was just amazing time and and
uh women were dames
i loved it you know dames is such a
great word and so uh
so i just kind of i wanted to capture
that in painting and i wanted
i want to kind of bring some of that
timelessness back and
and you know i would
i was really good with marker work uh
marker color comps
in animation because then i quickly
after that i became a character designer
and and so i spent the next you know 10
years in animation designing characters
for shows
and i ended on spongebob and that was
like uh steve hillenberg
a lot of my friends from a previous show
said hey we're going over nickelodeon
they got this new show
they're working on some pilot spongebob
and they need a character guy
and i met with steven and he said he
gave me marine biology books he's like
here make these characters
and uh i went home a marine biology book
yeah he was a marine biologist
yeah really he went to calarts he wasn't
the best draftsman but he had good ideas
and uh and he was really cool dude and a
surfer so why
marine biology was he just because it
was all about underwater
i don't know if you've ever seen the
show well i've seen it a few times with
my kids i never really paid attention
yeah it's just like i didn't know it was
underwater yeah
it's all finished bubble guppies is
underwater i don't know what that is
i i actually can't see you can watch
that with your kids i don't i the kids
have
so many shows going on and they're all
so horrible to watch so i don't stare at
anyone yeah bubble guppies was uh
my daughter's favorite show for like two
years yeah um
your style like but go to his website
and pull up some of the or pull some of
the images
of it you're are they all like this like
you you're you're st
do you do other kinds of styles or is it
most of your
work like cocktail party
i view my work as uh it's all
personality and relatable so
in my mind uh i'm gonna i'm not painting
art for your furniture or your living
room i'm not painting something you want
to put in your living room i'm painting
something that you want
that you identify with and uh i think a
lot of people
what do you mean by that like if it's
not for the living room like whereas if
you identify with yeah it's
wherever you identify put it where you
identify see yourself in it you see
yourself you see your boys
weekend at vegas that time you had the
greatest time ever the women
had girls night out and they see their
new stuff but it's awesome
instagram at all my new stuff cartoonish
oh okay
i hate that word what cartoonish
cartoonish yeah really
yeah what's a good word charactered
charactered but no one's gonna know what
you're saying i know i know
people there you go there's some new
stuff right there that's like the
foxes and um you know
so i always want to represent someone's
life i want them to see their life in it
i want them to see their personality in
there
go back to that picture again
the chasing foxes the blonde the like
from the left-hand side the third one
she looks like a [ __ ] oh good good
because then a group of four
looks like the main one that's the
fourth that's what you're gonna have
[ __ ] him
see everyone has their own hat better
everyone has their own attitude
everyone has their own personality like
out of those three you know why she gets
i think she likes the girl on the far
left the one the white that's my kind of
girl
smiling she seems like she's happy she's
soft that one
that one you got to work for that one
that's holding that wine glass too low
she's just too much work what do we like
we like the thrill of the hunt not the
thrill of the kill oh i like nice people
i get my thrills in other places i don't
want them in relationships a lot of
people
i look for conflict and relationships i
just look for nice people man
i like the white i lucked out yeah you
got lucky i did too
i like the one on the white that's my
kind of girl but that one that one with
the low wine glass i tell my friends bro
please please don't break the house
sugar shack
it's those three i have no problem with
any of those girls they're fine those
are fun i think
the one that jamie's got the cursor over
she's going to be the most problems
she's going to overdose at your house
she's going to see what are we doing
we're having conversations about stupid
art right like
so you know art should be a conversation
piece one of the far right she's going
to [ __ ] your friends
my friends you're going to go over my
clients she's going to text your friends
and then she's going to [ __ ] all your
friends yeah so it should be a
conversation piece you should have it in
an area where friends come over and they
go what's going on here
and it represents you it represents your
personality they say well this is how
you know we love our life but i know you
got to a point where you were like
really in demand like i remember i was
talking to eddie about it and he was
like
todd is so busy like he's like
constantly working
does it ever get to a point where it
seemed
like labor or like a that's a dope
hendrick shirt son
what you got there hidden by your gay
bandana i'm sorry
it's more like uh ranchers bandana there
you go we're in texas
yeah yeah he's gay would have sequence
in there or something
i like that that's a dope shirt you can
comment really
i'll give it to you well your game is
one of the coolest one of the coolest
shows i ever did i had the greatest fans
of any artist period living they're just
they're awesome people and they show up
in droves and
we were doing a show one time and this
this client in england came up and he
goes
and i said dude that's the greatest
jacket i've ever seen and he goes
you like it i go yeah he goes it's yours
and i go i'm not gonna take your jacket
and
in my mind i go i'm taking his jacket he
goes
he goes no man try it on if it fits you
it's yours and i thought that's a fair
fair i try it on i'm like oh buddy
perfect
he goes off to fix it because it's yours
wow oh thank you and the cool thing is
about
10 years later i was in toronto doing a
show and a kid came up
a artist kid he showed me his work
briefly which
i find a bit hard to look at people's
work in the middle of my show and i'm
like oh that's awesome dude
and he goes man that's a great jacket
and i go he was about my size i go
hey see if this fits you and he fit him
and i go it's yours
he was like over the moon i can't
believe it
and then other people were like dude i
just bought [ __ ] 60
painting you gave him a jacket like hey
come on man
you just gotta go with the pay forward
pay it forward you gotta go with the
flow
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience